each of the sculptures we make if
they're standing are 30 feet tall the
armature which is the structural
component which keeps it all together
it's made of a ten inch schedule 40 pipe
everything we create is made from
salvaged and repurposed materials so
it's all salvaged from various places
whether it was a structural steel shop
or we've gone to buildings that are
being demolished and actually will
remove pieces of them before the
building is torn down the environmental
message basically is asking people to
consider what happens next what what
comes after the oil economy and the
answer that this piece likes to proffer
is a return to worshipping nature you
know this is an intersection of art and
technology and the ideas and just to you
know have a pipe with fire coming out
but you want the fire coming out within
the structure of a sculpture and make it
seamless so it is all integrated and
it's about an integration that's that's
about that's all about what we're doing
together you know integrating our skills
and abilities to create something that's
both artistic and technological you know
which really can help inspire people to
think about possibilities for later
you